okay so we're gonna have a crack at this
question I expect the answer to be well
you know sometimes a textbook you end up
at some nice neat answer like 2 or minus
1 or something like that I expect this
to be a royal mess because the numbers
all came out of Kyle's head but that's
okay we can still solve it how do we go
about it now it's been a little while
no no I'm sure like if it if I've done
the same thing if I just made up numbers
the same thing would happen okay
I in fact a question has to be carefully
crafted to make sure it comes out with a
nice neat Ansan so this is us getting I
head back into algebra mode so that's
why we've got at X's here and the
question you'll get here would be solve
for X or find the value of x Peter
question okay sure all right so let's
begin what might be a good way to start
the question off Peter had his hand up
first so what would you do okay so it
lets a portrait ikut let's just work out
what we're doing
yes 54 we see all these brackets here
right and there a problem for us there
probably because we want to collect like
terms where the brackets are in the way
they kind of like walls you get rid of
them and then you can regroup things
okay so what we're doing here is we're
expanding brackets maybe you want to jot
down that that's what we're doing like
expanding brackets
that's what we're doing in this step
okay so we did six times X plus five
equals 6x Allie just told us that 6
times 9 is 54 okay 13 times these okay
so you're gonna get 39 here minus minus
78 like so good you can see this is
twice that because okay and that's equal
to now they're north brackets on this
side so that's done great
no more brackets or born so now at this
point the second thing I'll do is
collect like terms collect so this is
step one
this was step two okay so you can see
and you can even use different colors to
help you write I've got all of these X
terms I can see one yeah yeah okay so
what I'll try and do is get them all
over on one side over on the left okay
what if I got here I've got 6 minus 78
6-7 8 is minus 72 - 72 you know that
it's going to be minus 72 and not
positive 72 because how can you tell
this one's a positive well this one's
gonna take over isn't it clearly 78 more
important than the six okay good so I've
done that I want to bring this guy over
as well okay so I'm gonna subtract 3x
from both sides dedicate takeaway okay
so now just for myself right I've
accounted for this two of a kind of for
this stick kind of for that anyway
yeah yeah so I I want to get him a wall
over onto one side my last line is gonna
be x equals right ladies not helpful
okay now now what do we do
I've got to collect not just the X terms
but I'm gonna collect all of these
numbers in here right okay so another
color
my 54 matt39 and a negative two over
there okay
now 54 plus 39 that's a big number
okay but there are things you can do to
make it easier right
54 for staying out is hard but 54 plus
40 that's not so hard 54 40 that's gonna
be 94 but this is one less this is one
less okay so it'll be 93 okay so I've
got a plus 93 over here I already got
rid of this 3x tonight so just have -2
here so I collected a lot of like terms
but I'm not quite done yet
right now I have to account for this
part so minus 72 minus 3
hmm be careful these are both negative
they're both negative so that means it's
like you're way over there negatives
like to the left and then you're gonna
go even further to the left right so
that it's minus 75 X so watch after that
let's review terrain okay this is a
tricky part and this is an easy thing to
get wrong okay when you have minus 72
and minus 3 okay so minus 72 is where
you're starting from and then minus 3
makes it 3 further over in the negative
direction okay so it's like these tuning
is there sort of pooling together ok if
you want to think about this way it's a
little bit like um you know we often
think positive negatives a bit like you
know height up and down okay like
positive is up and negatives down well
this is like look I'm really far below
no ground level whatever and now I'm
gonna dig even further so that's why I'm
a bigger number okay even though it's
more negative okay now I have to do
those 93 hanging out over here I'm gonna
kick them over this side bye-bye - seen
taking away 93 from both sides ok so if
I take 93 away from this it'll be it'll
be the same thing minus 2 minus 95 minus
93 which is minus
okay right well done finally we've
collected all of the like terms okay
yeah yeah probably because you weren't
painted for the last 90 seconds okay now
therefore what am I gonna do with this
step oh we're done
I want to solve for X I want to get X
all by itself so I'm going to divide
everything through by minus 75 okay I'm
almost there
I've almost there really what I'm doing
now is I'm simplifying that's my last
step okay so I heard someone say five
times reported here yeah why is five
important very good ninety five and
seventy five they're both divisible by
five okay so if you wanted you could get
a calculator out to do this but I think
we can do it
95/5 I think it's nineteen because it's
one less than 100 right one mater five
less seventy five divided by five
fifteen I think you can double-check
that right and then you've got two
negatives they cancel the each other so
you either leave this 19 over 15 or we
could tidy it up just a little bit how
can we write it yeah that's right it'll
be 1 and 4/5 days as a mixed numeral
though I think night to no 15 is just
fine you you would Hannah Montana fig
specifically said provide it in a mixed
numeral now here's the thing like when
they say simplest for this mighty no 15
19 over 15 or 1 & 4 50s they're equally
simplified that's all
yeah yeah but-but-but - 95
/ - certified that's not simplified is
it that's not simplified we took out a
batch of five
we took out the negatives so you could
do more work to it but at this point
you're done